you went to Disneyland on your own yes I
did
would you like to tell us I will tell
you what happened okay you know lots of
children get circumcised mail lots of
children get circumcised and all of them
enjoy pumpkins just saying all right any
oh so um you you're talking about the
the Jewish ritual of the bris yeah but
but people they do it in the hospitals -
yeah of non Jewish children yeah
okay so anyhow but the bris they do it
it's called a moil he comes in he does
the Wiener chopping and I don't think
the Torah refers to it as Wiener
chopping they did the thing and then
when it when it was over the moil hands
me like a little sign of course yeah my
son my baby my older son James and they
you know didn't thing and he hands me
like a little metal envelope and he says
your son's foreskin is in here you need
to bury it for good luck I never heard
this part of the ritual before I didn't
know it until are you shouting at me
[Music]
crazy
tell you something you're just so funny
alright you are though you kill me boys
I don't make you alright
so I hand you the foil wrapping and has
the your son's foreskin in it in it yeah
and they say and they say bury it
someplace that means a lot to you I just
moved to LA hi Andy hi I just moved to
LA and I didn't have a special place per
se at that point now I have many where I
could bury a foreskin I love Los Angeles
okay so anyhow I'm walking down Sunset
Boulevard hooking and and there's a sign
that says come see the electric parade
that's it really 90 seconds what the
hell so I decide he doesn't good idea
what's up good job Steve go ahead okay
the minute he heard that you had your
son's foreskin in a foil I was proud he
just went up to 95 burners
why bigges let me jump I decide to go to
Disneyland because that's where I'm
gonna get rid of it and I'm gonna get at
Disneyland why Disneyland because it's
the closest thing to a special place for
me I love Disneyland what better place
for a flaw a better place I'm yelling
alright so I figure here's what I do I'm
gonna do a two-fold thing something I've
done it I'm gonna eat all the crappy
food and all the lands and then I've
given up junk food in honor of my son
the sore skin and I'll throw the
foreskin off at Pirates of the Caribbean
this is life this is my plan and it's
same person yeah in mind you well as you
go through Disneyland by yourself and
you go on rides and you eat people look
at you you can't you get in line that's
all these ppl was like I'm the old man
and so I was sitting in like Fantasyland
eating a giant turkey leg in a fantasy
and a family was staring at me and no
one knows who I am at this point so I
said I got to get out of here now and I
went over in front of Sleeping Beauty's
castle found a rock on the ground and
threw it and we don't wrap it around the
rock and it's by Sleeping Beauty's
castle
yeah
[Applause]
I don't know they're cleaning policies I
do know my other son it's at the Grove
in the fountain including him wait does
your family have a heard this story my
older boy knows that the younger one
doesn't know but they never watch
anything I'm on so there's no way right
so they're not gonna hear about this
it's not gonna hear what about your wife
does she know about this oh she knows
about it you okay she was not pleased
okay how about the good people at Disney
do they know
no they do all right season three of the
Goldbergs premieres September 23rd at
8:30 on ABC boy we're really in way in
advance
except enjoying your company and yelling
at you wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]